Russia could be gaining an
upper hand in
what is a fierce battle for Bakhmut.
British intelligence says that Moscow
is regaining
some momentum and has likely advanced
as far as the a town center there.
In a report out today, the U.K.
also said
that fighters
from the
both the Russian military
and that private Varg knit group
have paused their ongoing feud
and are now cooperating better.
Elsewhere in Ukraine,
at least seven
people were injured by shelling
in the southern region.
That's according
to the military administration there.
Want to get you to Nick
Paton Walsh,
who is in Kiev
with more on all of these developments.
And let's start,
if we can,
with what we understand
to be happening in Baku,
which at the moment,
I mean, this has been a month long battle
now sort of described as
sort of the epicenter of this war.
Just just provided some context
if you will, and any detail that we have
Look, I mean, the information
in this U.K.
intelligence report suggests
in their assessment
and these are
people who are continuing
analyzing everything they can lay
their hands on at a nature level.
They believe that
Russia is seeing incremental progress,
some sense of momentum.
But you have to remember, Becky,
in the broader picture of all of this,
this is a task that way.
Back at the beginning of the winter,
Russia
thought it might be able to achieve
in a matter of weeks.
And it is still now,
and you might argue six,
eight months, even continuing this.
Inch by inch bid to get more of it
back, moved in its hands.
Now, we've seen images today
suggesting that in the back
moving market,
there was continued
fighting with Ukrainian troops.
That's pretty much central.
At the same time, to their indications,
all the fighting is around
the train station, too.
So Ukraine still with forces in the West.
It does appear
the Russians have crossed over the river
and appear to have done
what they can to suggest
a stronger presence inside of that city.
But it comes at a staggering cost.
And of course, that is draining
resources of Russia,
which are already significantly depleted.
So add to that
to another problem for Moscow.
In the while,
they've been
pretty much throwing
everything
they can at trying to take back moves
that has allowed Ukraine,
possibly elsewhere in the country,
a chance to reset
or get ready for any counter
offensive coming as well.
They back back is of limited
strategic value.
Most assess it will enable them.
Certainly Russia,
if they take all of it
to have a better vantage
for other parts of Donbass,
they want to take as well.
But they've exhausted
so many thousands, it
seems, of troops in this particular fight
and it's dragged on so long.
But I think
any eventual final outcome of this battle
which Ukraine is
very keen to not let go of,
will come at a substantial cost
for Moscow Becky.
Nick, the Pentagon investigating
what appears
to be screenshots of classified U.S.
and NATO military information
about Ukraine,
which is circulating on social media.
I know that
we've had that confirmed
at least by a Pentagon official.
Do we have any more on this
Now, I have to be level with you, Becky.
This whole story is extremely odd.
The Pentagon have not
publicly said
that these are authentic documents.
And there's certainly
a lot of people wondering why on earth
if this was this one
narrative suggests
confidential information
obtained by Russia,
why would they tweak it as appears
to have been the case
and then posted up
on various social media channels?
It completely belie
the point of having
that confidential advantage
of knowing what your enemies assessment
of your capabilities
or Ukraine's capabilities. Indeed, are.
So that's also odd
to we've heard from Ukrainian officials
who are saying
this is all part of standard
Russian misinformation operation.
And Moscow
haven't directly commented
on this at all.
So it's an odd
piece of information to see out there.
There are suggestions
perhaps some of this information
may have been doctored or may be old,
but it really isn't clear
where it originated. From.
But it adds to one thing,
and that's the general sense
of anticipation
here, certainly
about when this counteroffensive
may begin.
We've had so much misinformation
over the past months particularly
when it came to the previous
Ukrainian counter
offensive back in the summer,
suggesting where
or they may
or may not choose to begin that fight.
But I think we should look
at these documents
whatever they really are
in that particular perspective.
And it remains to be seen
quite what they genuinely are.
But it does add to that broad sense
that something is certainly coming
and it's Ukraine's
turn on the battlefield
to make a move forward Becky.
Yeah.
Unclear when and what,
if anything, either
side knows about the other
others preparations for it.
Given your account there of it
being very unclear
what it is
that is circulating at this point.
Nick, it's
good to have you that Nick
Paton Walsh is in Ukraine to you folks.
Well, in northern north eastern Ukraine,
things are relatively calm
in the hockey region
near the Russian border.
Still Ukrainian forces
preparing for battle there.
CNN's Ben Wedeman found time to speak
to some of the show
soldiers as they shore up their defenses
have a look at this.
Zhenya prepares
his 50 caliber machine gun.
He didn't
fire this time,
but he needs to be always on alert.
Russian forces are nearby
This position
on the northern
edge of the Kharkiv region
hasn't seen much action of late,
but the men here have seen plenty.
Elsewhere, in January,
Zhenya was in a front line
foxhole in Donbass patrol.
From early in the morning.
They would shell us with artillery,
and right afterwards
their infantry would try
to take our positions, he recalls.
You could see them.
Much of the area
south of here saw vicious combat.
Last September,
Ukrainian forces
routed the Russians
for much of the Kharkiv region.
Before retreating,
they toppled the Soviet
era communications tower.
Scorched earth.
Their tactic of choice.
This position, manned
by the 209th Battalion
of the Ukrainian Army's
113th Brigade, is holding steady.
Defense, not offense, is the order of
the day.
Alexi
was a
nuclear physicist
before picking up a gun.
We have enough ammunition
and we have enough weapons and
different armor equipment.
But it's all for defense
equipment for the counterattack.
It will be better because of you.
So now free will help
The weapons they have are hardly
the latest.
The troops showed us
a Swedish made recoilless rocket launcher
dating back to 1978.
They defend their position
with other decades old methods
beyond this razor wire.
Just on the other side are land mines
Fortunately,
this area is relatively quiet,
which is a welcome
respite for these battle scarred troops.
No phone booth was a
nightmare is how you have gone describes
the battle in the dead of winter
in Donbas.
I'll remember it for the rest of my life.
52 year
old Vitale served with Russians
in the Soviet army.
This war has severed old ties.
You listen to we ate from the same pot
he says, reminiscing of his days
as a young recruit.
That was then.
This is now, after so many battles.
They prepare for the next
Ben Wedeman, CNN,
in the northern Kharkiv region.
The French president, Emmanuel
Macron, is now wrapping up
what has been a three day visit to China.
He was greeted by huge crowds at Sun
Yat sen
University on Friday,
where he spoke to students
on the campus later.
Mr.
Macron had a private dinner
with President
Xi Jinping
before meeting with Chinese investors.
On Thursday,
the two leaders
struck a deal on nuclear and wind energy.
They also discussed solutions
to end the war in Ukraine.
Mr.
Macron
hoping for a breakthrough
and counting on President Xi to reason
with Russia.
Aggression on Ukraine
about the Russian aggression
in Ukraine
has dealt a blow to the stability
it ended decades of peace in Europe.
I know I can count on you.
Moreover, under the two principles
I have just mentioned,
to bring Russia to its senses
and everyone to the negotiating table
in negotiation.
And we will come back to this in detail,
but we need to find a lasting peace
will Syrians, most who has been following
President Macron's
historic visit to China,
he joins us from Tokyo.
I just wonder what you believe
have been the wins for both sides here.
Let's start off with
with President Macron.
I mean,
he received an unusually warm
and lavish welcome from President Xi
What did he get out of this trip?
Well, Becky,
I think if we look back at this visit,
we really need to divide it
into two categories.
There's diplomacy
and then there is deal making
Let's first talk about diplomacy,
because all the attention
has been focused
on China's
influence in Russia
and the war in Ukraine.
We just got some remarks reported by
Chinese state media
within the last few hours
in which President Xi is quoted as saying
the war should not drag on
and that there should be a ceasefire.
But as we have witnessed
during this visit,
both sides
meeting France and China
really have not wavered
from their positions.
France really blaming
Russia for it for this war.
And China not necessarily condemning
Russia for its involvement in this war.
So things in many ways are still
status quo.
Despite these remarks,
no one
really is making any kind
of wholesale shift in position
However, according to French
diplomatic sources, President
Xi has agreed
to take a call with Vladimir Zelinski
when the time is right at the right
moment is the wording that
we have been reporting.